so this is great the two dudes that uh
Jesse smallett paid to beat him up
we're just on TV which they they pretty
much got off the hook right because they
just cooperated they were like Hey
listen buddy
this was all his plan honestly honestly
smart I'm smart on that yes that's not
stupid of them yeah so
um so of course now they are
free to tell their story this is great
you're gonna love this so this is them
this is them explaining exactly what
happened with smaller what they what he
had them do and all that stuff here you
go
they took our beautiful bench this is
where we waited for Jesse to come before
we attack them
so we got here with 10 minutes to spare
and we had to plan our Escape Route to
survey the land his building is actually
right here right above the stairs that
we're going to attack him at we made
sure we got there at 2 A.M sharp on the
dot on the dot we had no phones because
he did not can I just said can I already
say I don't know why do you think they'd
be chat too much up too they are that's
what king of all pixel says I actually
believe that I you know what I already
kind of like these guys
something about them I like they're just
being all mad all right look man that's
where he paid us so this is where we're
at it's where we're gonna pick him up I
didn't expect them to be this just like
chill and articulate oh they're really
cool I thought they were like just
Nigerian bodybuilders on the dot we had
no phones because he did not want us to
bring any phones he said so we don't
lose them I don't know if that's really
the reason but you can deduce your I
really like these guys they're fun one
reason so 2 A.M
he was nowhere to be found he was not
there so we were like damn what do we do
we didn't have no way of contacting him
he had no way of contacting us so we
waited here for about what four minutes
it was about four minutes four minutes
but it felt like forever because it was
cold as balls
okay I like these guys yeah they want me
over yeah
I'm a racist but you you've won me over
yeah usually I'm a racist but you didn't
want me over in this particular instance
I was like okay that's him let's go
gotta go get this Empire
oh yeah these guys
all right
so the lines that they're saying are the
lines Jesse had them say well obviously
but it's just like the way they're
saying it yeah okay that's him let's go
we gotta go get this Empire
look how he's walking that's him is that
him that's that
fast come on let's get them get that
[__] let's get him as we call it yes
bro I love these guys I love these guys
you know what it is for me the
enthusiasm they were excited to say that
[__] on Fox they're what The Hodgetwins
want to be that's yeah exactly it yeah
oh my God yes one day they wish they
were this fun they they wish they were
this naturally funny you know
hey oh we never get to do this hey
Trenton is that you
yeah
yes
we're walking like they're cold as [__]
too yeah also can I say it makes it even
funnier this is one of those Fox Nation
Originals that's playing this which
makes it even funnier across the street
we say hey to get his attention
hey Nick
they're white voices [__] hilarious
it's so good
oh [__]
the street we say hey to get his
attention hey Nick hey turn around
looked at us and that's when we started
yelling uh the famous slurs he wanted us
to yell hey aren't you that Empire
empire
I like that they're really milking it
now this is good this is so good
it's America country and he said what
did you say to me and then that's when I
threw the first punch at them
I held the blower because I didn't want
to hurt remember they're stunt men so
they they kind of knew all right yeah
they want to like [__] them up oh I made
it look
it look moving around yeah man like I
grew up in an Attitude Era and [__] and
like I know how to throw a work punch
you know what I'm saying I'm okay fave
dog I threw him to the ground he wanted
it to look like he fought back that was
very important yeah he wanted to look
tough that's Parts I love this part for
him because he said hey don't just beat
my ass make it look like I'm fighting
back and whatnot so we did that and then
I threw him to the ground and while
after I threw him to the ground I he had
no bruise I wanted it to look more real
so then I threw him to the ground after
I threw him to the ground I use my
knuckle and gave him a noogie so I went
like this
why did I do that to give him because he
wanted to make it look real
that's what that was on his cheek
get his ass beat after I did that I fake
kicked him I don't know what he was
doing I wasn't paying attention that's
where I came around with the Bleach the
infamous bleach in the hot sauce bottle
poured it on his shirt then I finally
put the Rope around his face I did not
put it around his neck I just placed it
on his face and that's when we took off
I like that just as a black guy he's
like I ain't put that [__] around his
neck bro I ain't like that bro I put on
his face he did whatever he want after
that dude that that's just like that's
the clip that that was so good right I
mean that [__] was amazing those
dudes [__] out of all the people
they're my favorite
a pick to try to help him with some [__]
he picked literally the two can we can
we can we do this part one more can we
do this part one more time
haha
definitely on a Redemption Arc yes hey
Nick
turned around looked at us last time we
started yelling uh the famous slurs he
wanted us to yell hey aren't you that
Empire
fat Nick
I would pay so much money to hear this
Jesus Christ it's you can hear it every
night just listen to your own show
Virgie no that is true though I would
give anything to cure that without the
police